As you may know, I love to shop for cardigans, skirts, and sandals this season. And when I do, I always make sure I get cash back from Rakuten. And it's not just clothing and shoes. You can get cash back from over 750 stores on electronics, travel, home decor, and more! Join for free at rakuten.ca! Start shopping and get your cash back sent to you by check or PayPal! Refer a friend and get Cha-ching for every friend you bring! $30 for you, $30 for them!
如你所知，我喜欢在这个季节购买开衫、裙子和凉鞋。每当这时，我总会确保通过乐天（Rakuten）获得现金返还。这不仅仅适用于服装和鞋子。你可以在超过750家商店购买电子产品、旅游产品、家居装饰品等，并获得现金返还！请在 rakuten.ca 免费加入！开始购物，并通过支票或 PayPal 领取你的现金返还！推荐朋友加入，每推荐一位朋友，你就能获得奖励！你得30美元，他们也得30美元！
Get the Rakuten app or join at rakuten.ca! Rakuten.ca Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app. Or on our website. February of 1960 was a cold month in the New Hampshire city of Manchester,
下载乐天应用程序或在 rakuten.ca 加入！Rakuten.ca 我们的剧集涉及严重且通常令人痛苦的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看你应用程序中本剧集的节目说明，或访问我们的网站。1960年2月，新罕布什尔州曼彻斯特市的那个月非常寒冷，
and a thick blanket of snow covered the ground. On Tuesday, February 2, an employee of Manchester Waterworks headed out to Lake Massabasic to conduct a routine search of the area. The four-square-mile lake required close monitoring as it provided the city's drinking water. The employee noticed that one of the drainage holes from the reservoir wasn't flowing properly. They got closer to get a better look and discovered that the drain was partially blocked by a red bag and a grey snow boot. Unsure what to make of the items, the employee turned them over to the police.
厚厚的积雪覆盖着地面。2月2日星期二，曼彻斯特水务局的一名员工前往马萨巴西克湖（Lake Massabasic）进行例行区域检查。这个四平方英里的湖泊需要密切监测，因为它为城市提供饮用水。该员工注意到水库的一个排水孔排水不畅。他们走近查看，发现排水口被一个红色的袋子和一只灰色的雪地靴部分堵住了。由于不确定这些物品是什么，该员工将它们交给了警方。
Around the same time, police received a call from a local couple named Charles and Irene Vellade. They were concerned as their 18-year-old daughter Sandra hadn't returned home the previous evening. Sandra had spent part of the day at a local factory where she worked as a secretary. Afterwards, she visited the library, saw a movie, and attended a swimming class. Around 9 p.m., Sandra boarded a bus to her parents' house and disembarked at the closest stop, approximately one mile from their property. The journey required her to walk down a dimly lit path near Lake Massabasic. She never made it home.
大约在同一时间，警方接到了一对当地夫妇查尔斯和艾琳·瓦拉德（Charles and Irene Vellade）的电话。他们很担心，因为他们18岁的女儿桑德拉（Sandra）前一天晚上没有回家。桑德拉当天在当地一家工厂做秘书。之后，她去了图书馆，看了一场电影，并参加了游泳课。晚上9点左右，桑德拉乘公共汽车前往父母家，并在离他们家大约一英里最近的车站下车。这段路程需要她走过马萨巴西克湖附近一条光线昏暗的小路。她最终没能到家。
Charles and Irene Vellade were shown the red bag and snow boot found stuck in the drain of Lake Massabasic. They confirmed the items belonged to their daughter. A large-scale search for Sandra Vellade commenced immediately. 200 volunteers and 60 troops from the National Guard braved the freezing conditions to search the heavily wooded area surrounding Lake Massabasic as a patrol plane flew overhead. They were on the lookout for the color red among the snowy landscape, as Sandra had been wearing a scarlet-colored blouse on the night she went missing.
查尔斯和艾琳·瓦拉德看到了在马萨巴西克湖排水口发现的红色袋子和雪地靴。他们确认这些物品属于他们的女儿。针对桑德拉·瓦拉德的大规模搜寻立即展开。200名志愿者和60名国民警卫队士兵冒着严寒，在马萨巴西克湖周围茂密的林区进行搜寻，一架巡逻机在头顶盘旋。他们在白雪皑皑的景观中寻找红色，因为桑德拉失踪当晚穿的是一件猩红色的衬衫。
Near the Lake Massabasic canal, they soon found another item, Sandra's coat. The garment was stained with blood, with droplets littering the surrounding snow and trailing to a nearby road. By the time Sandra had been missing for nine days, warmer weather partially thought some of the heavy snow that blanketed the area. On Wednesday, February 10, a motorist was driving along a quiet road 10 miles south of Sandra's home. All of a sudden, he noticed a flash of scarlet sticking out from a snow bank on the side of the road. The driver pulled over to investigate.
在马萨巴西克湖运河附近，他们很快发现了另一件物品——桑德拉的外套。这件衣服上沾满了血迹，周围的雪地上散落着血滴，并一直延伸到附近的一条路上。到桑德拉失踪九天时，天气转暖，部分融化了覆盖该地区的大量积雪。2月10日星期三，一名司机开车经过桑德拉家以南10英里处的一条安静道路。突然，他注意到路边的一个雪堆里闪过一抹猩红色。司机靠边停车进行调查。
On the other side of the snow bank, just a few feet from the road, Sandra Vellade's body lay on its side, her severely bruised face buried in the snow. She still wore the scarlet blouse, but was naked from the waist down. Investigators confirmed that Sandra's body had been concealed until a passing snow plow had disturbed the snow around her earlier that day. The cold conditions had preserved her body enough for a pathologist to conclude that Sandra had been sexually assaulted, violently beaten, stabbed, and shot four times with a .22 caliber rifle. Police believed that Sandra had likely accepted a lift home from the bus stop. She was then taken to the woods, where Sandra was attacked and ultimately killed.
在雪堆的另一侧，离路边仅几英尺远的地方，桑德拉·瓦拉德的尸体侧卧着，她那布满严重淤青的脸埋在雪里。她仍然穿着那件猩红色的衬衫，但腰部以下赤裸。调查人员证实，桑德拉的尸体一直被掩盖着，直到当天早些时候一辆经过的扫雪机扰动了她周围的积雪。寒冷的天气使她的尸体得以保存，病理学家据此得出结论：桑德拉曾遭到性侵、暴力殴打、刺伤，并被一把.22口径步枪射击了四次。警方认为，桑德拉很可能在公交车站搭了顺风车回家。随后她被带到树林里，在那里遭到袭击并最终被杀害。
Her body was then dragged to the snow bank where her killer attempted to bury her. He then discarded her belongings into the lake. In the woodland approximately two miles away, investigators uncovered the knife used in the attack. It was surrounded by blood stains and clumps of Sandra's hair. The .22 caliber rifle was nowhere to be found. Police believed the perpetrator was a local who was familiar with the quiet back roads where Sandra's body was found. On the night Sandra disappeared, a witness had been driving near the canal when they saw a dark-colored Chevrolet car driving along the icy road. The vehicle swerved into a snow bank where it got stuck momentarily
她的尸体随后被拖到雪堆处，凶手试图掩埋她。随后，他将她的物品扔进了湖里。在大约两英里外的林地里，调查人员发现了袭击中使用的刀。刀周围有血迹和一团团桑德拉的头发。那把.22口径步枪却不见踪影。警方认为凶手是当地人，熟悉发现桑德拉尸体的那条安静的小路。桑德拉失踪当晚，一名目击者在运河附近开车时，看到一辆深色的雪佛兰汽车沿着结冰的道路行驶。车辆滑入雪堆，暂时被困住，
before speeding away. The police appealed for anyone who had seen the Chevy to come forward. Horrified locals rallied around Charles and Irene Valade. Their daughter's funeral was held at a local church on Friday, February 12, two days after her body was found. Officers attended to observe the large crowd on the lookout for any suspicious behavior. One officer scant the cars parked at the church and noticed a black 1952 Chevrolet. The owner was a young man who was attending Sandra's funeral. The man was questioned in the back seat of his car before being arrested and taken in for interrogation. He was later released without charge.
随后加速离开。警方呼吁任何见过这辆雪佛兰的人挺身而出。惊恐的当地人聚集在查尔斯和艾琳·瓦拉德身边。2月12日星期五，也就是发现她尸体的两天后，桑德拉的葬礼在当地一座教堂举行。警察在场观察人群，寻找任何可疑行为。一名警官扫描了停在教堂的汽车，注意到一辆黑色的1952年款雪佛兰。车主是一名参加桑德拉葬礼的年轻人。该男子在车后座接受了盘问，随后被捕并带走审讯。他后来被无罪释放。
All other owners of black Chevrolet's in the area were looked into, but cleared of any involvement. The attorney general called Sandra Valade's death a barbaric slaying that could only be the product of some kind of human monster. He promised that no stone would be left unturned in finding Sandra's killer. Women and girls of Manchester were warned to stay indoors at night. School dancers and social events were cancelled. One of Sandra's friends who often accompanied her from the bus stop home received a phone call. The threatening voice on the other line simply said, you're next. Two weeks after Sandra Valade went missing, police were no closer to finding her killer.
该地区所有其他黑色雪佛兰车主都受到了调查，但均被排除了嫌疑。总检察长称桑德拉·瓦拉德的死是一场野蛮的杀戮，只能是某种人类怪物的产物。他承诺在寻找桑德拉的凶手时会不遗余力。曼彻斯特的妇女和女孩被警告晚上要待在室内。学校舞会和社交活动被取消。桑德拉的一位经常陪她从公交车站回家的朋友接到了一个电话。电话那头威胁的声音简单地说：“下一个就是你。”桑德拉·瓦拉德失踪两周后，警方在寻找凶手方面毫无进展。
A $1,500 reward was offered by members of the community, but it didn't lead to any breakthroughs. The one year anniversary of the murder came and went with no arrests. In February 1961, local authorities published an artist sketch in the newspaper. This was collated from a couple who had come forward soon after Sandra's body was found to say they had seen a man and a woman struggling in a car on the night Sandra disappeared. The sketch depicted a young man in his 20s with a narrow face and a long hair. The day the sketch was published, Sandra's mother received a phone call from an unknown male. He told her, so you got the picture in the paper, huh? You're next.
社区成员悬赏1500美元，但没有带来任何突破。谋杀案一周年过去了，仍未有人被捕。1961年2月，当地当局在报纸上公布了一张艺术家绘制的素描。这是根据一对夫妇提供的线索绘制的，他们在桑德拉尸体被发现后不久挺身而出，称在桑德拉失踪当晚看到一男一女在车里挣扎。素描描绘了一名20多岁的年轻人，脸型狭长，留着长发。素描发表当天，桑德拉的母亲接到了一个陌生男子的电话。他对她说：“所以你把照片登在报纸上了，是吧？下一个就是你。”
Five months later in July, 20-year-old Ronnie Jenkins, not his real name, was receiving mental health treatment at the New Hampshire State Hospital in Manchester. Ronnie walked from the hospital grounds to an unattended office nearby. There, he stole a .22 caliber rifle and walked nearly a mile to the state prison. Aiming the gun at the guard tower, Ronnie fired several shots before dumping the rifle on the street. Nobody was injured and Ronnie Jenkins was picked up by police and returned to hospital. When being questioned, he made an unexpected confession. He killed Sandra Valade. According to Ronnie, he knew Sandra from school. On the night of Monday, February 1, 1960,
五个月后的7月，20岁的罗尼·詹金斯（Ronnie Jenkins，化名）正在曼彻斯特的新罕布什尔州立医院接受心理健康治疗。罗尼从医院院子走到附近一个无人看管的办公室。在那里，他偷了一把.22口径步枪，走了近一英里来到州立监狱。罗尼将枪对准警卫塔开了几枪，然后把步枪扔在街上。没有人受伤，罗尼·詹金斯被警方抓获并送回医院。在接受盘问时，他做出了一个意想不到的供述：他杀了桑德拉·瓦拉德。据罗尼说，他从学校就认识桑德拉。1960年2月1日星期一晚上，
he saw her walking home from the bus stop and pulled over to offer her a lift. When Sandra refused, Ronnie became furious. He forced Sandra into his car, where she resisted his physical advances. Enraged, Ronnie assaulted Sandra before shooting her with a stolen gun and dumping her body in the snow. Investigators probed Ronnie for more details, but he couldn't offer any. They discounted him as a suspect, concluding he was a, quote, very disturbed individual who had likely made up the story to attract attention. The homicide investigation was back to square one.
他看到她从公交车站走回家，便靠边停车想让她搭顺风车。当桑德拉拒绝时，罗尼勃然大怒。他强行将桑德拉拉进车里，桑德拉反抗了他的身体接触。愤怒之下，罗尼袭击了桑德拉，随后用偷来的枪射杀了她，并将她的尸体扔在雪地里。调查人员向罗尼询问更多细节，但他无法提供。他们排除了他作为嫌疑人的可能性，断定他是一个“非常不安的个体”，很可能是为了博取关注而编造了这个故事。凶杀案调查回到了原点。
Four years later, 14-year-old Manchester teen Pamela Mason was eager to make some extra pocket money. In early January 1964, she visited the local laundromat with her friend Barbara. The girls placed a flyer on the bulletin board inside, offering babysitting services to the local community. The flyer worked. Days later, on the afternoon of Monday, January 13, Barbara received a call. A softly-spoken man on the other line asked if she was available to babysit that afternoon. A blizzard was approaching, so Barbara turned the job down on account of the poor weather. The man replied, I don't blame you. It's an awfully bad night for babysitting. Barbara told the man to try asking Pamela Mason instead.
四年后，14岁的曼彻斯特少女帕梅拉·梅森（Pamela Mason）渴望赚点零花钱。1964年1月初，她和朋友芭芭拉（Barbara）去了当地的自助洗衣店。女孩们在里面的公告栏上贴了一张传单，向当地社区提供保姆服务。传单起作用了。几天后的1月13日星期一，芭芭拉接到了一个电话。电话那头一个声音柔和的男子问她当天下午是否有空做保姆。一场暴风雪即将来临，所以芭芭拉因为天气恶劣拒绝了这份工作。该男子回答说：“我不怪你。这确实是个糟糕的保姆之夜。”芭芭拉告诉该男子试着问问帕梅拉·梅森。
Pamela's mother, Joan, answered his call. The man asked Joan if her daughter was available to babysit for the night. He didn't introduce himself, but said he lived up the road. Promised to drive Pamela home by 9pm. Joan didn't allow Pamela to babysit for strangers, but she agreed that Pamela could do the job as long as the man's wife picked her up. However, Pamela had yet to return home from school, so Joan told the man to call back a bit later. Joan then got ready for work as a waitress. As she left, she ran into Pamela and told her not to leave for the job unless a woman showed up. Pamela replied, oh mummy, don't worry. When Joan returned home from work at 3am, Pamela wasn't there. She often spent the night at a
帕梅拉的母亲琼（Joan）接了他的电话。该男子问琼她的女儿晚上是否有空做保姆。他没有介绍自己，但说他住在路的那头，并承诺在晚上9点前开车送帕梅拉回家。琼不允许帕梅拉给陌生人做保姆，但她同意只要该男子的妻子来接她，帕梅拉就可以做这份工作。然而，帕梅拉还没从学校回来，所以琼告诉该男子稍后再打来。琼随后准备去上班，做一名服务员。她离开时遇到了帕梅拉，告诉她除非有女人出现，否则不要去工作。帕梅拉回答说：“哦，妈妈，别担心。”当琼凌晨3点下班回家时，帕梅拉不在家。她经常在
friend's house, so Joan wasn't overly concerned. But when Pamela didn't show up for school the next day, Joan became worried. She called the police to report her daughter missing, telling them about the babysitting call. She also reported receiving suspicious phone calls in the lead-up to Pamela's disappearance. The details of these calls weren't publicly released. A massive search commenced. A neighbour had seen a car pull up at the Mason's house around 5.45pm. Pamela got in, but given the looming blizzard, they didn't get a good look at the driver or the vehicle. Neither Pamela's mother Joan nor her friend Barbara could provide much information about the mysterious caller. Joan described him as sounding between 20 and 30 years old. Barbara had asked
朋友家过夜，所以琼并没有太担心。但当帕梅拉第二天没去学校时，琼开始担心了。她打电话给警察报告女儿失踪，并告诉他们关于保姆电话的事。她还报告说在帕梅拉失踪前接到了可疑电话。这些电话的细节没有向公众披露。大规模搜寻开始了。一位邻居看到一辆车在下午5点45分左右停在梅森家门口。帕梅拉上了车，但由于暴风雪即将来临，他们没有看清司机或车辆。帕梅拉的母亲琼和她的朋友芭芭拉都无法提供关于神秘来电者的太多信息。琼形容他的声音听起来在20到30岁之间。芭芭拉曾问过
for his name, but he gave a weird-sounding laugh in response. Police appealed to the public to help identify the caller, but two days passed with no sign of Pamela. Her mother pleaded for her safe return, saying, whoever you are, for God's sake, don't harm my baby. Let her come home to me. I have no money, but if you want money, I'll get it somewhere. God let her be alive. On Saturday, January 18, five days after Pamela Mason went missing, a postal worker was sorting mail when he came across an unstamped empty envelope. Written on it were the words, P. Mason, Pine Island Amusement Park.
他的名字，但他回应了一阵听起来很奇怪的笑声。警方呼吁公众帮助识别来电者，但两天过去了，帕梅拉毫无音讯。她的母亲恳求她平安归来，说：“不管你是谁，看在上帝的份上，别伤害我的孩子。让她回家吧。我没钱，但如果你想要钱，我会想办法弄到的。上帝保佑她还活着。”1月18日星期六，也就是帕梅拉·梅森失踪五天后，一名邮政工人在分拣邮件时发现了一个没有邮票的空信封。上面写着：“P. Mason, Pine Island Amusement Park”（帕梅拉·梅森，松岛游乐园）。
Recognising the surname from the media coverage, the postal worker alerted police. Officers visited the abandoned amusement park on the outskirts of Manchester. They scoured the area, walking among the rides and empty stalls, but there was no sign of the missing teen. Two days later, a truck driver was travelling along Manchester's Interstate Route 93 when he noticed a blue object lying in the snow. He continued onwards, but the following day, he passed by again and noticed the object was still there. This time, he pulled over to investigate. It was a schoolbook belonging to Pamela Mason. In the snow nearby, he found examination papers belonging to Pamela, as well as her handbag. Walking through the melting snow about 20 feet
邮政工人从媒体报道中认出了这个姓氏，于是通知了警方。警察走访了曼彻斯特郊外废弃的游乐园。他们搜查了该地区，走在游乐设施和空摊位之间，但没有失踪少女的踪迹。两天后，一名卡车司机在曼彻斯特的93号州际公路上行驶时，注意到雪地里有一个蓝色的物体。他继续前行，但第二天他再次经过时，发现那个物体还在那里。这一次，他靠边停车进行调查。那是一本属于帕梅拉·梅森的教科书。在附近的雪地里，他发现了属于帕梅拉的考试卷以及她的手提包。走过融化的雪地，大约20英尺
from the road, the driver then discovered Pamela's body. She was fully clothed and lying face down. An autopsy determined she'd been savagely beaten before being shot twice in the back of the head with a .22 calibre rifle. She'd also been stabbed four times in the back and once in the chest. Her throat was cut, severing her jugular vein and windpipe. There were no stab wounds on Pamela's clothing, which indicated that she'd been naked when she was attacked and then redressed by her killer. Her underwear was missing, making it likely that a sexual assault had taken place. Forensic investigators estimated that Pamela Mason had been killed between 7 and 10 pm on the night she went missing. It was likely she'd been killed
离路边不远的地方，司机发现了帕梅拉的尸体。她穿着整齐，脸朝下躺着。尸检确定她在被枪杀前遭到了野蛮殴打，头部后方被.22口径步枪射击了两次。她的背部被刺了四次，胸部被刺了一次。她的喉咙被割开，切断了颈静脉和气管。帕梅拉的衣服上没有刺伤，这表明她在被袭击时是赤裸的，随后被凶手重新穿上了衣服。她的内衣不见了，这使得性侵犯很可能已经发生。法医调查人员估计帕梅拉·梅森是在失踪当晚7点到10点之间被杀害的。很可能她是在
elsewhere before her body was dumped in the snow on the side of the road. The similarities between Pamela's murder and that of Sandra Vallade four years earlier were too striking to ignore. The two crimes were, according to a medical examiner, nearly identical. The Manchester Chief of Police told the Associated Press, I'm very suspicious it could be the same person involved despite the four-year interlude. Locals were urged to be on the lookout for abandoned cars or buildings that appear to have been recently disturbed. Desperate to solve both cases, a $10,000 reward for information was offered by the governor. Once again, residents of Manchester were cloaked in terror.
别处被杀害，然后尸体被扔在路边的雪地里。帕梅拉的谋杀案与四年前桑德拉·瓦拉德的谋杀案之间的相似之处令人无法忽视。据法医称，这两起犯罪几乎完全相同。曼彻斯特警察局长告诉美联社：“尽管有四年的间隔，但我非常怀疑这可能是同一个人所为。”当地人被敦促留意那些看起来最近被扰动过的废弃汽车或建筑物。为了破获这两起案件，州长悬赏1万美元征集线索。曼彻斯特的居民再次笼罩在恐怖之中。
The principal at Pamela's high school told the students, I hope that this terrible tragedy will be a warning to all of you to be doubly careful in your undertakings. 53-year-old Rena Pequette lived on a farm in Manchester with her husband Arthur and their six children. Like many other locals, she'd been despondent over the news about Pamela Mason's murder. Shortly after the teenager's body was found, Rena turned to Arthur and said, I think I know who killed Pamela. Arthur scoffed, how could she know? Rena replied, the killer's mother told me. Rena worked at the laundromat where Pamela Mason and her friend Barbara had advertised
帕梅拉所在高中的校长告诉学生们：“我希望这场可怕的悲剧能给你们所有人一个警告，在你们的行动中要加倍小心。”53岁的雷娜·佩奎特（Rena Pequette）与丈夫亚瑟（Arthur）及六个孩子住在曼彻斯特的一个农场里。像许多其他当地人一样，她对帕梅拉·梅森被谋杀的消息感到沮丧。在少女的尸体被发现后不久，雷娜转向亚瑟说：“我想我知道是谁杀了帕梅拉。”亚瑟嘲笑道：“她怎么可能知道？”雷娜回答说：“凶手的母亲告诉我的。”雷娜在自助洗衣店工作，帕梅拉·梅森和她的朋友芭芭拉曾在那儿为她们的
their babysitting services. The flyer still remained pinned to the bulletin board. The owner of the laundromat had recently called Rena to say that she suspected her son, 27-year-old Edward Coolidge, was responsible for the murders of both Pamela Mason and Sandra Valade. The two women weren't particularly close, but Rena believed Edward's mother confided in her because she didn't have the heart to turn her son into the authorities. Arthur questioned why Edward's mother would single her out specifically. Rena responded, it's because he killed one of the girls in our pigsty. The pigsty on the Pequette farm had been built about half a mile away from the farmhouse,
保姆服务做过广告。传单仍然贴在公告栏上。洗衣店的老板最近打电话给雷娜，说她怀疑自己的儿子，27岁的爱德华·柯立芝（Edward Coolidge），应对帕梅拉·梅森和桑德拉·瓦拉德的谋杀案负责。这两个女人并不是特别亲近，但雷娜相信爱德华的母亲向她吐露心声，是因为她不忍心将自己的儿子交给当局。亚瑟质疑为什么爱德华的母亲会专门找她。雷娜回答说：“因为他在我们的猪圈里杀了一个女孩。”佩奎特农场的猪圈建在离农舍大约半英里远的地方，
so the residents didn't have to endure the smell. However, in recent years, the pigsty had been empty. Arthur found the idea preposterous. He didn't want Rena to get involved. But over the following days, Edward Coolidge's mother kept calling. She told Rena that Edward was unaccounted for on the night of Pamela's murder. Edward visited his mother at the laundromat often, and she believed he had seen Pamela's details and copied them down. Unable to deal with the mounting pressure, Rena Pequette called the local police to pass on what she knew. Two detectives visited Rena at her farm to interview her.
所以居民们不必忍受那种气味。然而，近年来，猪圈一直空着。亚瑟觉得这个想法荒谬至极。他不想让雷娜卷入其中。但在接下来的几天里，爱德华·柯立芝的母亲不断打来电话。她告诉雷娜，爱德华在帕梅拉被谋杀的那晚行踪不明。爱德华经常去洗衣店看望他的母亲，她相信他看到了帕梅拉的详细信息并抄了下来。无法承受越来越大的压力，雷娜·佩奎特打电话给当地警方，转达了她所知道的情况。两名侦探走访了雷娜的农场对她进行询问。
Two days later, on Monday, February 3, 1964, Rena's 15-year-old son, Danny Pequette awoke with a fright at 10am. Rena was meant to wake him up early for a doctor's appointment, but Danny had overslept. He climbed out of bed and went looking for his mother. The farmhouse was empty, with Danny's father and siblings having left hours earlier. Danny ran outside in the freezing cold and over to the barn. There was no sign of his mother anywhere. Unsure what to do, Danny called his police officer uncle who lived nearby. Together, they searched the house and barn.
两天后的1964年2月3日星期一，雷娜15岁的儿子丹尼·佩奎特（Danny Pequette）在上午10点惊醒。雷娜本应早点叫醒他去赴医生的预约，但丹尼睡过头了。他爬下床去寻找他的母亲。农舍里空无一人，丹尼的父亲和兄弟姐妹几小时前就离开了。丹尼跑到外面寒冷的空气中，冲向谷仓。到处都没有他母亲的踪迹。不知所措的丹尼打电话给住在附近的警察叔叔。他们一起搜查了房子和谷仓。
When they reached the end of the barnyard, Danny noticed something in the distance. Smoke was coming from the back of the Pequette farm, about half a mile away. Danny and his uncle trudged through the thick snow until they reached the area that was on fire. The blaze was coming from the interior of the pigsty. Two logs had been propped up against the door to prevent it being opened from the inside. Danny's uncle kicked the logs away and pulled open the door. Danny followed, ignoring his uncle's instructions to stay back. In the center of the pigsty, Rena Pequette was lying on her back, wearing a thin dress and slippers.
当他们到达谷仓院子的尽头时，丹尼注意到远处有些东西。烟雾正从佩奎特农场的后方冒出，大约半英里远。丹尼和他的叔叔在厚厚的积雪中跋涉，直到到达着火的区域。火势来自猪圈内部。两根原木被靠在门上，以防止从里面打开。丹尼的叔叔踢开原木，推开了门。丹尼跟着进去，无视叔叔让他留在后面的指示。在猪圈中央，雷娜·佩奎特仰面躺着，穿着一件薄裙子和拖鞋。
Her body had been set on fire. The ground around Rena's body was blackened, but the fire hadn't spread to the surrounding building. A coroner concluded that Rena had doused herself in a flammable liquid before lying down in a bed of straw and setting it on fire. The local newspaper reported that Rena Pequette took her life because she was depressed over the murders of Pamela Mason and President John F. Kennedy, who had been assassinated three months earlier. The Attorney General acknowledged that Rena had made a recent tip-off about Pamela Mason's killer, but clarified, quote,
她的尸体被点燃了。雷娜尸体周围的地面被烧黑了，但火势并没有蔓延到周围的建筑物。验尸官得出结论，雷娜在躺进稻草堆并点火之前，先给自己浇了易燃液体。当地报纸报道说，雷娜·佩奎特自杀是因为她对帕梅拉·梅森和三个月前被暗杀的约翰·F·肯尼迪总统的谋杀案感到沮丧。总检察长承认雷娜最近提供了关于帕梅拉·梅森凶手的线索，但澄清说：“引用，
There doesn't appear to be any connection between Mrs. Pequette's case and the murder of Pamela Mason. There is no basis for any of her suspicions which were made in a rambling way in numerous telephone calls to the police. I am satisfied the evidence that she suicided is conclusive. Rena's family were outraged. They refused to believe that Rena was depressed or would have taken her own life. Not only was she a devout Catholic who considered suicide a sin, there were simply too many unanswered questions. If Rena had doused herself in flammable liquid, why wasn't a container of liquid found at the scene?
佩奎特夫人的案件与帕梅拉·梅森的谋杀案之间似乎没有任何联系。她所有的怀疑都没有根据，这些怀疑是在多次给警方的电话中以语无伦次的方式提出的。我对她自杀的证据感到满意，结论是确凿的。”雷娜的家人感到愤怒。他们拒绝相信雷娜会抑郁或会结束自己的生命。她不仅是一位虔诚的天主教徒，认为自杀是一种罪，而且还有太多未解之谜。如果雷娜给自己浇了易燃液体，为什么现场没有发现液体容器？
If she'd voluntarily walked the half-mile from the farmhouse to the pig's die, why was she only wearing a light dress and slippers in the heavy snow? Furthermore, why had two logs being propped up against the outside of the door? It would have been impossible for Rena to do this from inside the pig's die. It also seemed highly suspicious that Rena had voiced her concerns about the pig's die being a crime scene, only to be found dead there herself days later. The Pequette family believed that Rena was already deceased when she was set alight. She was found lying flat on her back in a position that indicated she wasn't suffering as the flames burnt her body.
如果她是自愿从农舍走到半英里外的猪圈，为什么她在厚厚的积雪中只穿了一件轻便的裙子和拖鞋？此外，为什么门外靠着两根原木？雷娜不可能从猪圈里面做到这一点。雷娜表达了对猪圈作为犯罪现场的担忧，几天后自己却死在那里，这看起来也非常可疑。佩奎特一家认为雷娜在被点火时已经死亡。她被发现平躺在背上，姿势表明她在火焰灼烧身体时并没有受苦。
Rena's husband Arthur told reporters, I still believe that she was murdered and that her death was definitely connected with the Pamela Mason case. Even some of the officers who worked on the case doubted that Rena had killed herself. One later told the New Hampshire Union leader newspaper that they were ordered to forget their success. Adding, they even threatened to those who questioned the autopsy, saying they would be in very deep trouble if they pressed it further. Rena was late to rest at a simple ceremony attended by her close friends and family. When the Pequettes returned to the farmhouse,
雷娜的丈夫亚瑟告诉记者：“我仍然相信她是被人谋杀的，她的死绝对与帕梅拉·梅森案有关。”甚至一些参与此案的警官也怀疑雷娜是自杀的。其中一人后来告诉《新罕布什尔州联合领袖报》，他们被命令忘记他们的成功。并补充说，他们甚至威胁那些质疑尸检结果的人，说如果他们进一步追究，他们将陷入非常大的麻烦。雷娜在亲友参加的简单仪式中入土为安。当佩奎特一家回到农舍时，
they noticed another cloud of smoke rising from the back of their pyre. Someone had set the pig's die on fire again. Unbeknown to Rena Pequette, her colleague's son Edward Coolidge was already a person of interest in the Pamela Mason case before she phoned in her concerns. On the night the teenager went missing, two men had noticed a 1951 Pontiac sedan parked around 100 yards from where Pamela's body was eventually found. They approached the vehicle's driver's side window to see if the occupants needed any help. A man was sitting in the driver's seat. He appeared nervous and refused to look at
他们注意到另一团烟雾从他们的柴堆后方升起。有人再次点燃了猪圈。雷娜·佩奎特不知道的是，在她打电话表达担忧之前，她同事的儿子爱德华·柯立芝已经是帕梅拉·梅森案的嫌疑人。在少女失踪的那晚，两名男子注意到一辆1951年款的庞蒂亚克轿车停在离帕梅拉尸体最终被发现处约100码的地方。他们走近车辆的驾驶座车窗，看看车内的人是否需要帮助。一名男子坐在驾驶座上。他显得很紧张，拒绝看
them, instead staring straight ahead and saying he didn't need assistance. When Pamela Mason's body was discovered, the man reported this incident to the police in case it held significance. Owners of Pontiac sedans were looked into, leading police to 27-year-old bakery delivery driver Edward Coolidge, who was married with an infant daughter. On the night of Pamela's disappearance, Coolidge's neighbour visited to play cards with his wife. Coolidge was absent from 5-11pm. When he returned home, his trousers were wet to the knees. Coolidge offered no explanation, only saying, I feel lousy. He then went to have a bath. The following day, Coolidge told a co-worker he'd
他们，而是直视前方，说他不需要帮助。当帕梅拉·梅森的尸体被发现时，该男子向警方报告了这一事件，以防它具有重要意义。警方调查了庞蒂亚克轿车的车主，从而找到了27岁的面包配送司机爱德华·柯立芝，他已婚并有一个婴儿女儿。在帕梅拉失踪的那晚，柯立芝的邻居去他家和他妻子打牌。柯立芝从下午5点到晚上11点不在家。当他回到家时，他的裤子膝盖以下都湿了。柯立芝没有解释，只说：“我感觉糟透了。”然后他去洗了个澡。第二天，柯立芝告诉同事他
been out having an affair and needed an alibi. When Pamela's body was found, Coolidge told the co-worker, I really need that alibi now. Edward Coolidge was questioned on Tuesday, January 28, 1964, just days before investigators visited the Paquette farm to speak with Rena. When asked about his whereabouts on the night that Pamela Mason went missing, Coolidge first claimed that he'd been out shopping. He then changed his alibi and said he'd been having an extra marital affair. He then changed his story again, saying he was out playing cards. Police asked Coolidge to hand over any firearms he owned. He presented the officers with three, but a search of his home turned up one more, a .22 calibre rifle.
出去搞婚外情了，需要一个不在场证明。当帕梅拉的尸体被发现时，柯立芝告诉同事：“我现在真的需要那个不在场证明了。”爱德华·柯立芝于1964年1月28日星期二接受了盘问，就在调查人员前往佩奎特农场与雷娜交谈的前几天。当被问及帕梅拉·梅森失踪当晚的行踪时，柯立芝起初声称他出去购物了。随后他改变了不在场证明，说他在搞婚外情。接着他又改口说他出去打牌了。警方要求柯立芝交出他拥有的任何枪支。他向警官出示了三把，但对他的家进行搜查后又发现了一把，即一把.22口径步枪。
Edward Coolidge reluctantly participated in a light detector test, but the results were inconclusive. Without enough evidence to charge him, he was free to leave the station. The following day, Rena Paquette was found dead in the pig's die. Investigators refused to entertain the theory that Coolidge could have killed Rena. This was despite the fact that the day before Rena died, Coolidge had allegedly cornered her at the laundromat. Aware that she told the police of her suspicions, the two had a heated argument and Rena left in distress. She also received threatening phone calls in the days before her death, although the contents of these calls are not publicly known.
爱德华·柯立芝勉强参加了测谎仪测试，但结果不确定。由于没有足够的证据起诉他，他被允许离开警局。第二天，雷娜·佩奎特被发现死在猪圈里。调查人员拒绝考虑柯立芝可能杀害雷娜的理论。尽管事实上在雷娜去世的前一天，柯立芝据称在洗衣店把她逼到了角落。意识到她向警方表达了怀疑，两人发生了激烈的争吵，雷娜痛苦地离开了。她在去世前几天也接到了威胁电话，尽管这些电话的内容没有公开。
Still suspicious of Edward Coolidge's potential involvement in Pamela Mason's murder, police conducted a search of his car. Inside, they found a pair of bloodstained underwear confirmed to belong to Pamela. Two weeks after Rena Paquette's death, a grand jury indicted Edward Coolidge for the abduction and first-degree murder of Pamela Mason. Given the similarities between the two cases, Coolidge was also indicted to stand trial for the murder of Sandra Valade. A ballistics expert confirmed that bullets used in the attacks against both Pamela and Sandra were a 100% match to the .22 caliber rifle taken from Coolidge's home. The trial for Pamela Mason's case began in May 1964.
警方仍然怀疑爱德华·柯立芝可能参与了帕梅拉·梅森的谋杀案，于是搜查了他的车。在车内，他们发现了一条沾有血迹的内裤，经证实属于帕梅拉。雷娜·佩奎特去世两周后，大陪审团起诉爱德华·柯立芝绑架并一级谋杀帕梅拉·梅森。鉴于两起案件的相似之处，柯立芝也被起诉，将因谋杀桑德拉·瓦拉德而受审。弹道专家证实，在针对帕梅拉和桑德拉的袭击中使用的子弹与从柯立芝家中查获的.22口径步枪100%匹配。帕梅拉·梅森案的审判于1964年5月开始。
Edward Coolidge took the stand to proclaim his innocence. When asked why he had changed his alibi so many times, he replied, Because I was scared, and that's the truth. I was so nervous that I did not know what I was saying. It took just over four hours for the all-male jury to find Edward Coolidge guilty. He went visibly pale and began trembling as the verdict was delivered. Despite being eligible for the death penalty, the judge sentenced Coolidge to life imprisonment. Outside, a crowd of 1,000 Manchester locals had gathered. As Coolidge was led from the courtroom, angry citizens called him an animal,
爱德华·柯立芝出庭宣称自己无罪。当被问及为什么多次改变不在场证明时，他回答说：“因为我害怕，这是事实。我太紧张了，以至于不知道自己在说什么。”全男性陪审团仅用了四个多小时就裁定爱德华·柯立芝有罪。当判决宣布时，他脸色明显苍白，开始颤抖。尽管符合死刑条件，法官还是判处柯立芝终身监禁。在外面，1000名曼彻斯特当地人聚集在一起。当柯立芝被带出法庭时，愤怒的市民称他为动物，
screaming that he, quote, should have been hung. A reporter asked if he had anything to say. Coolidge looked at him, a cigarette hanging from his mouth, and muttered, Talk to my lawyers. As detailed in the book Our Little Secret by Kevin Flynn and Rebecca Lavoy, the Attorney General didn't bring forward the indictment for Sandra Velarde's murder. When asked why, he explained, We already got Coolidge for one. No need to get him for two.
尖叫着说他“应该被绞死”。一名记者问他有什么话要说。柯立芝看着他，嘴里叼着一支烟，嘟囔道：“去跟我律师谈。”正如凯文·弗林（Kevin Flynn）和丽贝卡·拉沃伊（Rebecca Lavoy）在《我们的秘密》（Our Little Secret）一书中所详述的那样，总检察长没有对桑德拉·瓦拉德的谋杀案提起诉讼。当被问及原因时，他解释说：“我们已经抓到一个柯立芝了。没必要再抓他第二次。”
While Edward Coolidge served his life sentence, the Paquette family struggled to come to terms with Reena's death and the feeling of injustice. They were convinced that Coolidge had killed Reena for implicating him in Pamela Mason's murder, and that authorities had downplayed it to avoid further public hysteria. Danny Paquette, who had found his mother's burning body, continued to be haunted by the case. He tried to move on with his life, eventually enlisting in the military and marrying a woman named Denise. Danny officially adopted Denise's one-year-old daughter, Melanie, and the couple went on to have two more children. But by 1980, their marriage had fallen apart. Denise prevented Danny from seeing his children,
当爱德华·柯立芝服终身监禁时，佩奎特一家努力接受雷娜的死亡和不公正的感觉。他们确信柯立芝因为雷娜指控他参与帕梅拉·梅森的谋杀案而杀害了她，而当局为了避免进一步的公众歇斯底里而淡化了此事。发现母亲燃烧尸体的丹尼·佩奎特继续被此案困扰。他试图继续生活，最终参军并娶了一位名叫丹妮丝（Denise）的女子。丹尼正式收养了丹妮丝一岁的女儿梅兰妮（Melanie），这对夫妇后来又有了两个孩子。但到了1980年，他们的婚姻破裂了。丹妮丝阻止丹尼见他的孩子，
which sent him into a fury. A physical altercation ensued, prompting Denise to apply for a restraining order and file for divorce. Danny violated the restraining order and threatened to kill Denise. At a subsequent hearing, he attempted to attack a bailiff. As a result, he was sent to hospital to receive mental health treatment. There, he was questioned extensively about his mother Reena's death and underwent hypnosis to revisit the morning that Reena died. Danny suddenly recalled a previously unknown detail. On the morning of Monday, February 3, 1964, he'd woken to the sound of his mother arguing with someone. Danny went to investigate. Reena was standing at the bottom of the stairs with a man in a white uniform, the same kind that Edward Coolidge wore on his bakery delivery route.
这让他陷入了狂怒。随后发生了肢体冲突，促使丹妮丝申请了限制令并提出离婚。丹尼违反了限制令并威胁要杀死丹妮丝。在随后的听证会上，他试图袭击一名法警。结果，他被送往医院接受心理健康治疗。在那里，他被广泛询问关于他母亲雷娜死亡的情况，并接受了催眠以重温雷娜去世的那天早晨。丹尼突然回忆起一个以前未知的细节。1964年2月3日星期一早上，他被母亲与人争吵的声音吵醒。丹尼去查看。雷娜站在楼梯底部，和一个穿着白色制服的男人在一起，那正是爱德华·柯立芝在面包配送路线上穿的那种制服。
Scared, Danny ran back to his room. Although there was no evidence to support this repressed memory, it strengthened the Paquette family's belief that Coolidge had killed Reena. Danny planned to write to Coolidge in prison and later confront him in person in the hope he would finally admit his involvement. When Danny was discharged from hospital in 1981, his ex-wife Denise feared for the safety of herself and her children. They fled to Alaska without telling Danny where they were going and he lost contact with his children altogether. Things didn't get any easier for Danny. Shortly after his release from hospital, he was riding a motorbike with his new girlfriend on the back when a car pulled out in front of them. Danny was lucky to walk away with minor
害怕的丹尼跑回了自己的房间。虽然没有证据支持这段被压抑的记忆，但这加强了佩奎特一家认为柯立芝杀害了雷娜的信念。丹尼计划写信给监狱里的柯立芝，并希望以后能当面与他对质，希望他最终能承认自己的参与。当丹尼于1981年出院时，他的前妻丹妮丝担心自己和孩子的安全。他们逃到了阿拉斯加，没有告诉丹尼他们要去哪里，他与孩子们彻底失去了联系。丹尼的情况并没有好转。出院后不久，他骑着摩托车带着新女友，一辆车突然开到他们面前。丹尼很幸运，只受了轻伤，
injuries, but his girlfriend died in the crash. By 1985, things had taken a positive turn for Danny Paquette. The 36-year-old welder by trade was living in Hooksett, a small town less than 10 miles north of Manchester. The house was on an 11-acre property surrounded by woodland which allowed Danny to run his own welding business and restore cars and motorcycles in his spare time. Scrap metal, spare tires and other car parts littered the yard along with large welded sculptures. Danny was a talented artist and passing motorists often pulled over to take photos of his work. He had plans to one day sell his art and donate the money to the Boston Children's Hospital. On the morning of Saturday, November 9, 1985, Danny walked down to the large shed on his property
但他的女友在车祸中丧生。到了1985年，丹尼·佩奎特的情况有了好转。这位36岁的焊工住在曼彻斯特以北不到10英里的一个小镇胡克斯特（Hooksett）。房子坐落在一块11英亩的土地上，周围环绕着林地，这让丹尼可以经营自己的焊接业务，并在业余时间修复汽车和摩托车。废金属、备用轮胎和其他汽车零件散落在院子里，还有大型焊接雕塑。丹尼是一位才华横溢的艺术家，路过的司机经常停下来为他的作品拍照。他计划有一天卖掉他的艺术品，并将钱捐给波士顿儿童医院。1985年11月9日星期六早上，丹尼走到他房产上的大棚子里
to begin work for the day. He was joined by a friend who was conducting some car repairs. Danny also employed a local 17-year-old named Court to help him with odd jobs. At 11am, Court showed up and began helping Danny to weld a metal plate on a bulldozer which was located outside of the shed. Danny then sent Court into the shed to mix and paint while he continued to work on the bulldozer. Shortly after, Court was heading back outside when a large cracking sound pierced the air. Danny Paquette was lying flat on his back in front of the bulldozer. His welding torch still on in his hands. Panicked, Court raised back inside the shed and summoned Danny's friend. Thinking that Danny had been electrocuted,
开始一天的工作。一位正在进行汽车修理的朋友加入了他的行列。丹尼还雇了一名当地17岁的年轻人考特（Court）来帮他做杂活。上午11点，考特出现并开始帮助丹尼焊接推土机上的金属板，推土机位于棚子外面。丹尼随后让考特进棚子去搅拌油漆，而他继续在推土机上工作。不久之后，考特正要往外走，一声巨大的破裂声刺破了空气。丹尼·佩奎特平躺在推土机前。他的焊枪还在手中开着。惊慌失措的考特跑回棚子里叫来了丹尼的朋友。以为丹尼触电了，
Court ran to call 911. Danny's friend then commenced CPR. As he pushed on Danny's chest, he noticed blood beginning to seep out under his hands. He opened Danny's shirt. That's when he realized Danny hadn't been electrocuted. He'd been shot. An autopsy determined Danny had been killed by a single gunshot wound fired from a distance of at least 200 yards. The bullet had entered through the centre of Danny's chest and exited from his left shoulder, indicating the shooter had fired from a lower point to where Danny had been standing. Either they had a fantastic aim and could hit a very small target from a great distance, or it had been a freak accident. Danny had been killed on the first day of the hunting season.
考特跑去打911。丹尼的朋友随后开始进行心肺复苏。当他按压丹尼的胸部时，他注意到血开始从他的手下渗出。他打开丹尼的衬衫。就在那时，他意识到丹尼不是触电了。他被枪击了。尸检确定丹尼死于从至少200码外射出的一发子弹。子弹从丹尼胸部中心射入，从左肩射出，表明射手是从比丹尼站立位置更低的地方开火的。要么他们瞄准极好，能从很远的地方击中一个非常小的目标，要么这是一场离奇的事故。丹尼死于狩猎季节的第一天。
The area around his house was a popular hunting spot. There was also a quarry located one mile from Danny's home where hunters were known to fire test rounds into a gravel pit. This led detectives to consider that Danny might have been shot accidentally. They urged anyone who had been hunting in the area to come forward. A neighbour reported seeing cars parked at a nearby hiking trail on the day Danny was shot, and unidentified footprints were found leading into the woods 80 yards from Danny's shed. But it couldn't be ascertained whether these held significance to the investigation. Detectives scoured Danny's property. With such a vast area to cover, they were unable to locate the bullet that killed him. Without it, they had very little to go on.
他家周围是一个受欢迎的狩猎点。离丹尼家一英里处还有一个采石场，猎人们常在那里向碎石坑发射测试弹。这导致侦探们认为丹尼可能是意外中枪。他们敦促任何在该地区狩猎的人挺身而出。一位邻居报告说，在丹尼中枪当天看到汽车停在附近的一条徒步小径上，并在离丹尼棚子80码处的树林里发现了不明脚印。但无法确定这些是否对调查具有重要意义。侦探们搜查了丹尼的房产。由于覆盖面积太大，他们无法找到杀死他的子弹。没有它，他们几乎没有什么线索。
Coincidentally, a local man had been travelling overhead in a hot air balloon at the exact time Danny was killed and had been filming the journey. He provided police with a videotape giving them a complete bird's eye view of Danny's property. Detectives watched the tape with interest. No people were visible in the footage and tall trees obscured some of the view, as promising as it had seemed, the footage offered no leads. Three days after Danny Pickett's death, a telephone maintenance worker received a call out to check the phone lines on the street where Danny lived. Some other residents had complained that their lines had been out of service over the past few days.
巧合的是，一名当地男子在丹尼被杀的同一时间乘坐热气球在头顶上方飞行，并拍摄了整个旅程。他向警方提供了一盘录像带，让他们可以鸟瞰丹尼的房产。侦探们饶有兴趣地观看了录像带。镜头中没有出现人，高大的树木遮挡了部分视野，尽管看起来很有希望，但录像带没有提供任何线索。丹尼·佩奎特去世三天后，一名电话维修工接到电话，去检查丹尼居住街道上的电话线。其他一些居民抱怨说，他们的线路在过去几天里一直无法使用。
The maintenance worker tested the telephone poles. All were working except one which was positioned directly at the front of Danny's home. The maintenance worker climbed to the top of the pole to get a closer look. Contained in the plastic covering of the wires was a red and white 270-colour bullet. A ballistics expert determined it was the bullet that killed Danny Pickett. The red and white colouring was caused by blood and bone fragments. Over the following days, detectives interviewed hunters in the area, many of whom turned over their guns for testing. None were rematched to the bullet. Some doubted whether a hunter would choose the area around Danny's house.
维修工检查了电线杆。除了丹尼家正前方的那根外，其余的都能正常工作。维修工爬到杆顶仔细查看。在电线的塑料外壳里，嵌着一颗红白相间的270口径子弹。弹道专家认定这就是杀死丹尼·皮克特的子弹。红白相间的颜色是由血迹和骨头碎片造成的。接下来的几天里，侦探们走访了该地区的猎人，许多人交出了他们的枪支进行测试。没有一支枪与这颗子弹匹配。一些人怀疑猎人是否会选择丹尼家周围的区域。
It was surrounded by mud, sand and gravel and wasn't known to attract much game. A conservation officer said, I'd be very surprised to find anybody there hunting. If I were going hunting in that general area, that's probably the last place I'd go. It became more likely that Danny's death had been the result of a homicide. But 12 days passed with very few leads, leaving investigators scratching their heads. Danny's brother, Victor Pickett, remained optimistic, telling the Concorde Monitor, Somehow, some day, we will have an answer as to what went down on the day he was killed.
那里被泥土、沙子和砾石包围，并不以吸引猎物而闻名。一位保护官员说：“如果我在那里发现有人打猎，我会非常惊讶。如果我要在那个大区域打猎，那可能是我最后会去的地方。”丹尼的死是谋杀结果的可能性变得更大了。但12天过去了，线索寥寥无几，调查人员对此感到困惑。丹尼的兄弟维克多·皮克特仍然保持乐观，他告诉《康科德箴言报》：“无论如何，总有一天，我们会得到关于他被杀那天到底发生了什么的答案。”
A year after Danny Pickett's death, detectives were no closer to solving his case. They followed all sorts of leads, but to no result. Victor refused to give up hope. He told reporters, I've been out there to Danny's property. I've been up and down on my hands and knees. I was looking for anything that didn't grow there. Shell casings, a piece of paper, a cigarette butt. Anything. Victor had a growing suspicion that his brother's death was related to the pigsty fire that killed their mother, Rena, nearly 20 years earlier.
丹尼·皮克特去世一年后，侦探们在破案方面毫无进展。他们追踪了各种线索，但都没有结果。维克多拒绝放弃希望。他告诉记者：“我去过丹尼的房产。我跪在地上四处搜寻。我在寻找任何不属于那里的东西。弹壳、一张纸、一个烟头。任何东西。”维克多越来越怀疑他兄弟的死与近20年前导致他们母亲雷娜死亡的猪圈火灾有关。
In October 1990, he appeared on the popular television program Unsolved Mysteries, to raise his concerns that both Rena and Danny Pickett had been murdered. A ballistics expert agreed, saying it was impossible that Danny had been killed by a stray bullet. While Victor continued to search for answers, convicted killer Edward Coolidge sat in a jail cell. His time in prison had been eventful. Seven years into his life sentence, he appealed his case on the grounds that the search of his vehicle that uncovered Pamela Mason's bloody underwear had been unconstitutional. The search warrant had been signed off by the Attorney General,
1990年10月，他出现在受欢迎的电视节目《未解之谜》中，表达了他对雷娜和丹尼·皮克特都被谋杀的担忧。一位弹道专家表示同意，称丹尼不可能死于流弹。当维克多继续寻找答案时，被定罪的杀手爱德华·柯立芝正坐在监狱牢房里。他的狱中生活并不平静。在他被判终身监禁七年后，他以搜查其车辆并发现帕梅拉·梅森血迹斑斑的内衣属于违宪为由，对案件提出了上诉。搜查令是由总检察长签署的，
who later became the lead prosecutor at Coolidge's murder trial. The Constitution maintained that whoever signed off on the warrant needed to be a neutral and detached magistrate. In June 1971, the Supreme Court agreed that the search had violated the Fourth Amendment. In a landmark decision, Edward Coolidge was awarded a retrial. However, several key witnesses in the Pamela Mason case had since passed away. The state offered Coolidge a deal instead. Plead guilty to second-degree murder, and they'd downgrade his life sentence to 25 to 40 years jail, including time already served. Coolidge agreed.
他后来成为了柯立芝谋杀案审判的首席检察官。宪法规定，任何签署搜查令的人都必须是中立且超然的治安法官。1971年6月，最高法院同意该搜查违反了第四修正案。在一项具有里程碑意义的裁决中，爱德华·柯立芝获得了重审机会。然而，帕梅拉·梅森案的几位关键证人已经去世。州政府转而向柯立芝提供了一项协议。承认二级谋杀罪，他们将把他的终身监禁减为25至40年监禁，包括已服刑的时间。柯立芝同意了。
Although Edward Coolidge was still behind bars at the time Danny Paquette was shot, Victor Paquette was convinced he was somehow responsible. Perhaps Coolidge had taken a hit out on Danny to keep him quiet about what he saw on the morning his mother was killed. After serving 27 years in jail, Edward Coolidge walked free from prison in March 1991 at the age of 53. The anger from the community was so extreme that Coolidge was released on the condition that he never returned to New Hampshire. Pamela Mason's father told the Boston Globe, wherever Coolidge goes, I'll find him. Then I'll saturate the community so they know what kind
尽管丹尼·帕奎特被枪杀时爱德华·柯立芝仍在狱中，但维克多·帕奎特确信他以某种方式负有责任。也许柯立芝雇人杀害丹尼，是为了让他对母亲被杀那天早上所见的事情保持沉默。在服刑27年后，爱德华·柯立芝于1991年3月以53岁的高龄获释出狱。社区的愤怒如此强烈，以至于柯立芝获释的条件是他永远不得回到新罕布什尔州。帕梅拉·梅森的父亲告诉《波士顿环球报》：“无论柯立芝去哪里，我都会找到他。然后我会让那个社区的人都知道他是什么样的人。”
of guy he is. They say time heals all wounds. That's baloney. I am going to make his life as miserable as he has made mine. The unsolved mystery segment didn't generate any worthwhile leads in either of the Paquette cases, but authorities did agree that Reena's body could be exhumed to allow for another autopsy to be conducted. 27 years had passed since Reena's death and they hoped this would put her family's concerns to rest once and for all. It was a bit of sweet moment for Victor Paquette who told the Associated Press, for every member of this family this was an unwanted thing. We didn't want to have to go to this extreme. On Wednesday, November 13, 1991, the Paquette family watched as Reena's coffin was exhumed from St. Joseph Cemetery. Convinced further
他们说时间能治愈一切伤口。那是胡扯。我要让他过得像他让我过得一样痛苦。《未解之谜》节目并没有为帕奎特案中的任何一起案件提供有价值的线索，但当局确实同意可以挖掘雷娜的遗体，以便进行另一次尸检。雷娜去世已经27年了，他们希望这能让她的家人彻底放下心来。这对维克多·帕奎特来说是一个苦乐参半的时刻，他告诉美联社：“对于这个家庭的每个成员来说，这是一件不情愿的事情。我们不想走到这一步。”1991年11月13日星期三，帕奎特一家看着雷娜的棺材从圣约瑟夫公墓被挖掘出来。确信进一步
testing would one day be necessary, her husband Arthur had insisted that Reena be placed in a black body bag inside a sealed casket and then into a vault. Because of this, her remains were still in fairly good condition. However, Arthur had since passed away without receiving any answers about his wife's mysterious death. The state medical examiner conducted an autopsy and compared it to the original findings. He agreed that Reena's death had been caused by fire. However, he believed that Reena was unconscious when her body was set alight. The original autopsy report also contained a detail that Reena's family had been unaware of. At the time of her death, traces of semen were found on her body. Reena's husband Arthur was
的测试终有一天是必要的，她的丈夫亚瑟坚持将雷娜装进一个黑色尸袋，放入密封的棺材，然后再放入墓穴中。正因为如此，她的遗体状况仍然相当良好。然而，亚瑟在没有得到关于妻子神秘死亡的任何答案的情况下已经去世了。州法医进行了尸检，并将其与最初的调查结果进行了比较。他同意雷娜的死因是火灾。然而，他认为雷娜在身体被点燃时已经失去了知觉。最初的尸检报告还包含了一个雷娜家人不知道的细节。在她去世时，她的身体上发现了精液痕迹。雷娜的丈夫亚瑟
never questioned to confirm whether the two had been intimate around the time of her death. Was it possible that Reena had also been raped? The medical examiner found the case deeply troubling. He told the New Hampshire Union leader, I cannot sustain suicide as a manner of death. I do not see any way this can be called a suicide. He changed Reena's official cause of death to indeterminate. The year after Reena Pequett's body was exhumed, the Pequett family appeared on a New Hampshire talk show hosted by local media personality Kathy Burnham. They were joined by Richard Barron, a family friend who had paid for Reena's exhumation.
从未被询问以确认两人在她去世前后是否有过亲密关系。雷娜是否也可能被强奸了？法医觉得这个案子非常令人不安。他告诉《新罕布什尔州联合领袖报》：“我无法维持自杀作为死亡方式的结论。我看不到任何将其称为自杀的理由。”他将雷娜的官方死因改为“不确定”。雷娜·帕奎特遗体被挖掘出来的第二年，帕奎特一家出现在由当地媒体名人凯西·伯纳姆主持的新罕布什尔州脱口秀节目中。与他们一起参加节目的还有理查德·巴伦，他是支付了雷娜挖掘费用的家庭朋友。
They reiterated their belief that the deaths of Reena and Danny were connected and pleaded for anyone with information to come forward. A week later, Richard Barron received two anonymous letters from two different authors. As detailed in Our Little Secret, one read in part, Something has been eating away at me, but I have been afraid to step forward. Seeing the pain the family is suffering persuaded me to do so. The family is wrong to conclude that Danny Pequett's death is connected to his mother's death. The second letter revealed, I am dumbfounded as to how the case is still unsolved. It is a bad example to the many young people who know the facts about this murder.
他们重申了他们认为雷娜和丹尼的死有关联的信念，并恳求任何有信息的人站出来。一周后，理查德·巴伦收到了两封来自不同作者的匿名信。正如《我们的小秘密》中所述，其中一封写道：“有些事情一直折磨着我，但我一直害怕站出来。看到这个家庭遭受的痛苦，我决定这样做。这个家庭认为丹尼·帕奎特的死与他母亲的死有关，这是错误的。”第二封信透露：“我感到震惊的是，这个案子怎么到现在还没破。对于许多了解这起谋杀案事实的年轻人来说，这是一个坏榜样。”
It is common knowledge in Hopkinson that a young man named Eric Winterst shot Danny Pequett with his father's 270 rifle. Eric Winterst has misled the police very successfully. It is said that he keeps his friends quiet on his dealings through charm, through intimidation, and through threats. The New Hampshire State Police went about verifying the accuracy of the letters. At the time Danny Pequett was killed, Eric Winterst had been a 17-year-old high school student in Hopkinson, North Hampshire. It was a small town with a population of around 4,000 people and located approximately 15 miles north of Danny's home.
在霍普金顿，一个名叫埃里克·温特斯特的年轻人用他父亲的270口径步枪射杀了丹尼·帕奎特，这已是众所周知的事实。埃里克·温特斯特非常成功地误导了警方。据说他通过魅力、恐吓和威胁让他的朋友们保持沉默。新罕布什尔州警方开始核实这些信件的准确性。丹尼·帕奎特被杀时，埃里克·温特斯特是新罕布什尔州霍普金顿的一名17岁高中生。那是一个人口约4000人的小镇，位于丹尼家以北约15英里处。
Eric was a popular and friendly team with piercing blue eyes and dark wavy hair. He came from a wealthy family who owned property throughout Hopkinson. In the years since graduating high school, Eric Winterst had enlisted in the U.S. Marine Corps, but he was medically discharged due to being severely allergic to ant bites. He moved to Colorado in 1989, where he was arrested for second-degree burglary after stealing some cases of beer from a restaurant. He received six months probation and a fine. Other than that, his record was unblemished. Investigators tracked Eric Winterst down to question him about Danny Pequett's shooting,
埃里克是一个受欢迎且友好的少年，有着深邃的蓝眼睛和深色的波浪发。他来自一个富裕的家庭，在霍普金顿各地拥有房产。高中毕业后的几年里，埃里克·温特斯特加入了美国海军陆战队，但因对蚂蚁叮咬严重过敏而被医疗退伍。1989年，他搬到科罗拉多州，因从一家餐馆偷了几箱啤酒而被捕，罪名是二级入室盗窃。他被判处六个月缓刑并处以罚款。除此之外，他的记录清白。调查人员追踪到埃里克·温特斯特，询问他关于丹尼·帕奎特枪击案的情况，
but under advice from his lawyers, he invoked his right to remain silent. Police interviewed Eric's father, who handed over his Ruger rifle. It was compared against the bullet taken from the telephone pole outside Danny Pequett's home, but it wasn't a match. There was still one lead worth pursuing. Both letters implicating Eric Winterst in the murder of Danny Pequett gave the reason for the shooting. After Danny's ex-wife Denise relocated to Alaska with their three children, they never saw Danny again. They didn't even attend his funeral. But unbeknown to Danny, in the year before his death,
但在律师的建议下，他行使了保持沉默的权利。警方采访了埃里克的父亲，他交出了他的鲁格步枪。它与从丹尼·帕奎特家外的电线杆上取下的子弹进行了比对，但并不匹配。还有一个值得追踪的线索。两封暗示埃里克·温特斯特参与谋杀丹尼·帕奎特的信件都给出了枪击的原因。在丹尼的前妻丹妮丝带着他们的三个孩子搬到阿拉斯加后，他们就再也没有见过丹尼。他们甚至没有参加他的葬礼。但丹尼不知道的是，在他去世前的一年里，
his 15-year-old stepdaughter Melanie had been living just 15 miles away. Melanie's maternal aunt and uncle lived in Hopkinson, and they had invited Melanie to stay with them for summer vacation. The couple were financially well off with distinguished careers. This was in stark contrast to Melanie's life in Alaska, where her mother Denise worked hard just to make ends meet. Melanie loved her vacation to Hopkinson so much that when she returned to Alaska, she asked Denise if she could move there. Hopkinson High School had a good academic reputation, and it would provide her the opportunity to make new friends.
他15岁的继女梅兰妮就住在离他仅15英里远的地方。梅兰妮的姨妈和姨夫住在霍普金顿，他们邀请梅兰妮去和他们一起度暑假。这对夫妇经济宽裕，事业有成。这与梅兰妮在阿拉斯加的生活形成了鲜明对比，在那里，她的母亲丹妮丝努力工作只是为了维持生计。梅兰妮非常喜欢她在霍普金顿的假期，以至于当她回到阿拉斯加时，她问丹妮丝她是否可以搬到那里。霍普金顿高中的学术声誉很好，这将为她提供结交新朋友的机会。
Denise agreed, and in late August of 1985, three months before Danny Pequett's death, Melanie moved in permanently with her aunt and uncle. Melanie hadn't seen Danny for four years, and she wanted nothing to do with him. The move was kept secret, but Melanie and Denise worried what Danny would do if he found out. Regardless, Melanie adjusted fairly well to life in Hopkinson. She made friends easily and was proud to become the only girl to play on the high school soccer team. Melanie particularly hit it off with a fellow soccer player, 17-year-old Eric Winterst. He and Melanie started spending lots of time together,
丹妮丝同意了，1985年8月下旬，也就是丹尼·帕奎特去世前三个月，梅兰妮永久搬去和她的姨妈姨夫住在一起。梅兰妮已经四年没见过丹尼了，她不想和他有任何瓜葛。这次搬家是保密的，但梅兰妮和丹妮丝担心如果丹尼发现了会做出什么事。无论如何，梅兰妮相当好地适应了霍普金顿的生活。她很容易交到朋友，并为成为高中足球队中唯一的女孩而感到自豪。梅兰妮特别喜欢和另一位足球运动员、17岁的埃里克·温特斯特相处。他和梅兰妮开始花很多时间在一起，
and it wasn't long before Melanie developed romantic feelings for her new friend. Eric really cared about Melanie, but told his friends that he thought of her more as a little sister. A sister he needed to protect at all costs. Melanie Pequett had since lost contact with Eric Winterst. She had gotten married and moved to California. When investigators tracked her down in 1992, she said she was too busy looking after her young children to answer any questions. Instead, an officer sent her a series of questions regarding Danny's death. Melanie returned her answers a week later. In response to the question of whether Eric Winterst had any reason to shoot Danny, Melanie wrote,
没过多久，梅兰妮就对她的新朋友产生了浪漫的情愫。埃里克真的很关心梅兰妮，但告诉他的朋友们，他把她更多地看作是一个小妹妹。一个他必须不惜一切代价保护的妹妹。梅兰妮·帕奎特此后与埃里克·温特斯特失去了联系。她结婚并搬到了加利福尼亚州。当调查人员在1992年追踪到她时，她说她太忙于照顾年幼的孩子，无法回答任何问题。相反，一名警官给她寄了一系列关于丹尼死亡的问题。梅兰妮在一周后寄回了她的答案。在回答埃里克·温特斯特是否有任何理由射杀丹尼的问题时，梅兰妮写道：
In my opinion, he did not have any reason to shoot Danny. Without any physical evidence to corroborate the rumors, the police couldn't press charges. Over a year later in October 1993, a New Hampshire journalist named Michael Manzo was writing an article about a murder trial. The case was only solved because a witness had given police the name of the killer. The story had a profound effect on Michael. Once he finished writing the article, he called the police and told them that Melanie Pequett was his college girlfriend. In September 1988, she confided in him that she and Eric Winterst had killed Danny Pequett. Michael offered to call Melanie on a tapped line to see if he could get
“在我看来，他没有任何理由射杀丹尼。”由于没有任何物证来证实这些传言，警方无法提起诉讼。一年多后的1993年10月，一位名叫迈克尔·曼佐的新罕布什尔州记者正在写一篇关于谋杀案审判的文章。这个案子之所以能破，是因为一名证人向警方提供了杀手的名字。这个故事对迈克尔产生了深远的影响。写完文章后，他打电话给警方，告诉他们梅兰妮·帕奎特是他大学时的女朋友。1988年9月，她向他吐露，她和埃里克·温特斯特杀害了丹尼·帕奎特。迈克尔主动提出在监听电话中给梅兰妮打电话，看看能否让她
her to confess. It had been a long time since the two had spoken. After exchanging pleasantries, Michael broached the subject of Danny's death. Melanie denied ever having the conversation, telling Michael that she was in a dark place when they were dating and often made up stories for attention. Unable to get any information out of her, the case went cold once again. Eleven years went by before the New Hampshire State Police were awarded additional funding that allowed them to reopen the case. In July 2004, two officers knocked on Melanie's door. By this point, she had relocated to Idaho, had five children and was a devout Mormon. It had been almost 20 years since Danny Pequett was killed. Melanie agreed to accompany the
坦白。两人已经很久没有交谈了。在寒暄之后，迈克尔提到了丹尼死亡的话题。梅兰妮否认有过这样的谈话，告诉迈克尔，他们在约会时她处于一段黑暗时期，经常编造故事以博取关注。由于无法从她那里得到任何信息，案件再次陷入僵局。十一年过去了，新罕布什尔州警方获得了额外的资金，使他们能够重新调查此案。2004年7月，两名警官敲开了梅兰妮的门。此时，她已经搬到了爱达荷州，有五个孩子，是一名虔诚的摩门教徒。距离丹尼·帕奎特被杀已经过去了近20年。梅兰妮同意陪同
officers to the station to answer some questions. When they asked her to take a polygraph, Melanie's face went pale. She nonetheless agreed. As the technician hooked her up to the machine, she became visibly anxious. She asked if she could have a moment to say a prayer. The technician agreed and left the room. When he returned, Melanie was crying. She said she was finally ready to tell the truth. As a new student at Hopkinson High School, Melanie was relieved for Eric Winterst's friendship. As the two became closer, Melanie confided in Eric about a secret she'd been keeping since she was nine years old. Her stepfather Danny Pequett had sexually abused her repeatedly until her family fled to Alaska when Melanie was 11. Melanie told Eric that after Danny raped her,
警官去警察局回答一些问题。当他们要求她进行测谎时，梅兰妮的脸变得苍白。尽管如此，她还是同意了。当技术员把她连接到机器上时，她变得明显焦虑。她问是否可以给她一点时间祈祷。技术员同意并离开了房间。当他回来时，梅兰妮正在哭泣。她说她终于准备好说出真相了。作为霍普金顿高中的一名新生，梅兰妮对埃里克·温特斯特的友谊感到宽慰。随着两人关系变得亲密，梅兰妮向埃里克吐露了一个她从九岁起就一直保守的秘密。她的继父丹尼·帕奎特反复对她进行性虐待，直到她的家人在梅兰妮11岁时逃往阿拉斯加。梅兰妮告诉埃里克，丹尼强奸她后，
he would hold a gun to her head and pull the trigger. She never knew if the gun was loaded or not. Danny used this to keep Melanie quiet, threatening to kill her if she spoke out. He also forced her to hang from a chin up bar and threatened to burn her with his welder's torch if she let go. Sometimes, he forced Melanie to watch while he killed small animals. Eric Winterst was outraged and devastated for his friend. Melanie's suffering also hit close to home, as Eric's father had sexually assaulted his stepsisters when Eric was just a child. Too young to act on the abuse at the time, Eric channeled all of his anger onto Danny Pequett. In early November 1985, Eric was sitting with a friend in the school gymnasium when he called
他会用枪指着她的头并扣动扳机。她从来不知道枪里是否有子弹。丹尼利用这一点让梅兰妮保持沉默，威胁说如果她敢说出去就杀了她。他还强迫她挂在引体向上杆上，并威胁说如果她松手就用焊枪烧她。有时，他强迫梅兰妮看着他杀死小动物。埃里克·温特斯特为他的朋友感到愤怒和悲痛。梅兰妮的痛苦也触动了埃里克，因为埃里克的父亲在埃里克还是个孩子时就曾性侵过他的继姐妹。当时太小而无法对虐待采取行动，埃里克将他所有的愤怒都发泄在了丹尼·帕奎特身上。1985年11月初，埃里克和一位朋友坐在学校体育馆里，他叫
Melanie over. In a harsh voice, he said, We've been talking about the situation with your stepfather. Do you want him dead? Melanie replied, Yeah, I want him dead. Days later, on the morning of Saturday, November 9, Eric Winterst phoned Melanie with an announcement. He was going to Danny Pequett's home to kill him. Melanie pleaded to go with him. Eric didn't know what Danny looked like, so he agreed. He drove over to Melanie's house in his Volkswagen Rabbit. Melanie told her aunt and uncle the pair were going to a high school hockey game. They then drove the 15 miles to Danny's house. Along the way, they stopped at a gas station. As detailed in the book Our Little Secret, the attendant who topped up the gas noticed
梅兰妮过来。他用严厉的声音说：“我们一直在谈论你继父的情况。你想让他死吗？”梅兰妮回答说：“是的，我想让他死。”几天后，在11月9日星期六的早上，埃里克·温特斯特给梅兰妮打电话宣布了一个消息。他要去丹尼·帕奎特的家杀了他。梅兰妮恳求和他一起去。埃里克不知道丹尼长什么样，所以他同意了。他开着他的大众兔子车去了梅兰妮家。梅兰妮告诉她的姨妈和姨夫，他们要去参加一场高中曲棍球比赛。然后他们开车15英里去了丹尼家。途中，他们在加油站停了下来。正如书《我们的小秘密》中所述，加油的服务员注意到
a rifle in the back of Eric's car. He remarked to Eric that it was a good day for hunting. Once they arrived on Danny's street, Eric parked his car further down in an area hidden by bushes and covered his license plates with mud. He and Melanie then walked through the neighbouring woods until they arrived at Danny Pequett's property. They sat on a stone wall concealed by woodland. Melanie could see Danny working in his yard, and she pointed him out to Eric. Eric popped a stick of chewing gum into his mouth, and the pair sat in silence. As Eric chewed, he turned to Melanie and said, When my gum runs out of flavour, I'm going to do it.
埃里克的车后座有一支步枪。他向埃里克评论说，这是打猎的好日子。到达丹尼所在的街道后，埃里克把车停在远处一个被灌木丛遮挡的地方，并用泥土盖住了车牌。他和梅兰妮随后穿过邻近的树林，直到到达丹尼·帕奎特的房产。他们坐在被林地遮蔽的石墙上。梅兰妮可以看到丹尼在院子里工作，她指给埃里克看。埃里克往嘴里塞了一块口香糖，两人静静地坐着。当埃里克咀嚼时，他转向梅兰妮说：“当我的口香糖没味儿时，我就动手。”
Eric left Melanie and walked to the treeline on Danny's property. The shell of an old car sat a few feet away. Eric crawled up to the car and rested his rifle on the hood. He could see Danny working on the bulldozer approximately 300 yards in the distance. Eric took aim. He was an expert marksman. He fired and watched as Danny fell to the ground. The pair ran back to Eric's car and drove past Danny's house, trying not to draw attention to themselves. They went to a nearby Burger King restaurant to kill time. If anyone later asked, their plan was to say they were at the hockey game.
埃里克离开梅兰妮，走到丹尼房产的树线处。几英尺外停着一辆旧车的残骸。埃里克爬到车旁，把步枪架在引擎盖上。他可以看到丹尼在约300码远的地方修理推土机。埃里克瞄准了。他是一位神枪手。他开枪了，看着丹尼倒在地上。两人跑回埃里克的车，开车经过丹尼家，尽量不引起注意。他们去了附近的一家汉堡王餐厅消磨时间。如果以后有人问起，他们的计划是说他们当时在看曲棍球比赛。
A friend of Eric's had promised to verify their alibi. Over the next few days, Melanie expected the police to come looking for her, but days turned into weeks, and nothing happened. Seven weeks after Danny was killed, detectives finally interviewed Melanie and Eric. They both stuck to their false alibi, which Eric's friend corroborated. Meanwhile, rumors spread throughout Eric's group of friends that he had killed Danny Pickett as an act of vigilantism for abusing Melanie. Some wrestled with the idea of turning Eric in, but ultimately no one went to the police,
埃里克的一位朋友答应为他们提供不在场证明。接下来的几天里，梅兰妮一直等着警察来找她，但日子一天天过去，什么也没发生。丹尼被杀七周后，侦探们终于采访了梅兰妮和埃里克。他们都坚持他们虚假的不在场证明，埃里克的朋友也对此进行了佐证。与此同时，埃里克的朋友圈里传言说，他杀害丹尼·皮克特是为了替梅兰妮遭受的虐待进行私刑报复。一些人纠结于是否要举报埃里克，但最终没有人去警察局，
with many believing that Danny Pickett's murder was justified. After finally revealing the truth to the police, Melanie agreed to call Eric Winters in a bid to corroborate her story. Although they hadn't spoken in many years, he seemed pleased to hear from her. As detailed in Our Little Secret, Melanie told Eric that investigators were on their way to Idaho to speak with her. She didn't know whether to cooperate with them or not. Eric advised Melanie to get a lawyer and said he didn't want to speak about it over the phone. He offered to get on a plane and speak to Melanie in person. Melanie said, I'm really sick of this. Eric replied,
许多人认为丹尼·皮克特的谋杀是正当的。在终于向警方吐露真相后，梅兰妮同意给埃里克·温特斯特打电话，试图证实她的故事。虽然他们已经很多年没说话了，但他似乎很高兴听到她的声音。正如《我们的小秘密》中所述，梅兰妮告诉埃里克，调查人员正在前往爱达荷州的路上与她谈话。她不知道是否应该与他们合作。埃里克建议梅兰妮找个律师，并说他不想在电话里谈论这件事。他主动提出坐飞机亲自去和梅兰妮谈。梅兰妮说：“我真的受够了。”埃里克回答说：
Yeah, well I am too. I've tried just to live my life every day and live it as well as I possibly can. Not a day goes by I don't think about all this. Not a day goes by I don't think about you and how you're doing. Melanie said she was going to tell the investigators that Eric had killed Danny. When he reacted calmly, she asked why he wasn't freaking out. Eric explained, I've been scared about this my whole life. Maybe I've lived with this so long I'm at peace with whatever happens. It's out of my hands. Melanie called Eric a few more times. Despite her attempts to elicit a confession, Eric Winters wasn't talking. Investigators would have to use another tactic. They travelled across the country to speak with those who knew Eric in high school.
“是啊，我也是。我每天都试着过好自己的生活，尽可能过得好。没有一天我不想到这一切。没有一天我不想到你，想到你过得怎么样。”梅兰妮说她要告诉调查人员是埃里克杀了丹尼。当他冷静地反应时，她问他为什么不惊慌。埃里克解释说：“我这辈子一直为此感到害怕。也许我和这件事共存太久了，无论发生什么我都心安理得。这已经不在我的掌控之中了。”梅兰妮又给埃里克打了几个电话。尽管她试图诱导他坦白，但埃里克·温特斯特什么也没说。调查人员必须采取另一种策略。他们跨越全国去采访那些在高中时认识埃里克的人。
Once his former friends learned that Melanie had confessed, the walls of silence came crumbling down. The fact that Eric had killed Danny Pickett was an open secret. In fact, Eric would tell new friends and lovers about what he'd done. He allegedly told a girlfriend that after shooting Danny, he chopped the gun into pieces and scattered them along a drive to Colorado. Others who knew admitted they hadn't come forward out of fear that Eric would retaliate violently. Years after Danny was killed, Eric confided in his friend Theo about his role in the murder. Theo wrote about Eric's confession in her personal diary, unsure whether to believe it. I thought I knew him so well. How could he live with himself,
一旦他以前的朋友得知梅兰妮已经坦白，沉默之墙就崩塌了。埃里克杀害丹尼·皮克特是一个公开的秘密。事实上，埃里克会告诉新朋友和恋人他所做的事情。据称，他告诉一位女朋友，在射杀丹尼后，他把枪切成碎片，沿着去科罗拉多的路扔掉了。其他认识他的人承认，他们没有站出来是因为害怕埃里克会进行暴力报复。丹尼被杀多年后，埃里克向他的朋友西奥吐露了他在谋杀案中的角色。西奥在她的个人日记中写下了埃里克的坦白，不确定是否该相信。我想我对他太了解了。他怎么能过得去自己那一关，
she wrote, before conceding. I want to take the only way out and just forget about it. Assume it's just a rumor. But what if it's true? Eric Winters was arrested in December 2005. Two days later, a grand jury formally charged him with first degree murder. He pleaded not guilty, but changed his mind when offered a plea bargain. By pleading guilty to the lesser charge of second degree murder, he avoided going to trial. Eric Winters was sentenced to serve 15 to 36 years at the New Hampshire State Prison. At the hearing, Eric turned to the Paquette family and said, I have no words to express how sorry I am for what I've done. I just hope someday that you can forgive
她写道，然后承认：“我想找唯一的出路，就把它忘了。假设这只是个传言。但如果是真的呢？”埃里克·温特斯特于2005年12月被捕。两天后，大陪审团正式指控他犯有一级谋杀罪。他拒不认罪，但在获得认罪协议后改变了主意。通过承认较轻的二级谋杀罪，他避免了审判。埃里克·温特斯特被判在新罕布什尔州监狱服刑15至36年。在听证会上，埃里克转向帕奎特一家说：“我无法用言语表达我对所作所为的歉意。我只希望有一天你们能原谅
me. A victim impact statement read on behalf of Danny's sister said, Were it in my power, I would have everyone that was part of this 21 year secret, some would say cover up, be standing beside Mr Eric Winters to share in his guilt and sentencing. The question remained, what to do with Melanie? In December 2006, she faced a hearing to determine an appropriate punishment. Throughout the investigation, Melanie had maintained that she didn't believe Eric was serious about his plan to kill Danny. Despite being at the scene of the crime and withholding the truth for almost two decades, Melanie faced no charges relating to the murder of Danny Paquette. Instead, for lying on the written questionnaire that was sent out
我。”一份代表丹尼姐妹宣读的受害者影响陈述说：“如果我有权力，我会让所有参与这个21年秘密——有人会说是掩盖——的人，都站在埃里克·温特斯特先生身边，共同分担他的罪责和刑罚。”问题仍然是，如何处理梅兰妮？2006年12月，她面临一场听证会以确定适当的惩罚。在整个调查过程中，梅兰妮一直坚称她不相信埃里克会真的去杀丹尼。尽管身处犯罪现场并隐瞒真相近二十年，梅兰妮没有面临任何与丹尼·帕奎特谋杀案相关的指控。相反，因为在寄出的书面问卷中撒谎，
in 1992, she was charged with felony hindering apprehension. Danny's family were outraged. A majority of them refused to believe that Danny was an abuser. Melanie had admitted to making up other stories in her teenage years, including telling people that she had cancer. Some of the Paquette's believed her claims of sexual assault were another false fabrication. A victim impact statement read by one of Danny's nieces said, We're here because you convinced a human being to murder another human being. You used 21 years of our suffering to build a life. You orchestrated this murder. Without you, there wouldn't have been a murder.
1992年，她被控犯有重罪——妨碍逮捕。丹尼的家人感到愤怒。他们中的大多数人拒绝相信丹尼是一个虐待者。梅兰妮曾承认在青少年时期编造过其他故事，包括告诉别人她患有癌症。一些帕奎特家人认为她关于性侵犯的指控是另一个虚假的捏造。丹尼的一位侄女宣读的受害者影响陈述说：“我们在这里是因为你劝说一个人去谋杀另一个人。你利用我们21年的痛苦来建立自己的生活。你策划了这场谋杀。没有你，就不会有这场谋杀。”
Melanie pleaded guilty to the charge. Her attorney requested that any sentence be suspended due to the emotional and physical abuse Melanie had suffered at the hands of her adoptive father. The presiding judge doubted Melanie's claims that she didn't know Eric was going to go through with the shooting. He said, I guess I have real difficulty in accepting the idea that at some point the lights didn't go on. He sentenced Melanie to three to six years in prison, adding, My heart goes out to your family. It is clear you have done some tremendous things with your life since this tragedy. In October 2020, Eric Winterst was up for parole after serving 15 years. Victor Paquette appeared in his online parole hearing, in which he held up a photo of Danny
梅兰妮对指控表示认罪。她的律师请求暂停任何刑罚，理由是梅兰妮在养父手中遭受了情感和身体虐待。主持法官怀疑梅兰妮关于她不知道埃里克会真的去射杀丹尼的说法。他说：“我想我真的很难接受在某个时刻她没有意识到这一点。”他判处梅兰妮三至六年监禁，并补充说：“我的心与你的家人同在。很明显，自从这场悲剧发生以来，你在生活中做了一些了不起的事情。”2020年10月，埃里克·温特斯特在服刑15年后获得假释机会。维克多·帕奎特出现在他的在线假释听证会上，他举起了一张丹尼的照片
for Eric to see. Look familiar, he said. Is this the man you saw in your rifle sights? Let me help you with this. Loving brother, respected and well-liked businessman, and most of all, a loving and caring father. To the anguish of the Paquette family, Eric Winterst was granted parole. He eventually resettled in his hometown of Hopkinson, New Hampshire, where he was generally welcomed by the public. Many thought he had served enough time, while others continued to believe the crime was justified. Eric's father died in July 2016. No charges were ever brought against him for the alleged sexual abuse of his stepdaughters, as the statute of limitations had run out before
让埃里克看。“看着眼熟吗？”他说，“这就是你在步枪瞄准镜里看到的那个人吗？让我帮你回忆一下。慈爱的兄弟，受人尊敬和喜爱的商人，最重要的是，一位慈爱和关怀的父亲。”令帕奎特一家痛苦的是，埃里克·温特斯特获得了假释。他最终回到了他的家乡新罕布什尔州霍普金顿，在那里他受到了公众的普遍欢迎。许多人认为他已经服刑足够长的时间，而另一些人则继续认为这起犯罪是正当的。埃里克的父亲于2016年7月去世。他从未因涉嫌性侵继女而受到任何指控，因为在指控曝光之前，诉讼时效已经过了。
the allegations were brought to light. When writing his book, Our Little Secret, author Kevin Flynn visited Eric Winterst in prison. Eric showed great remorse over his actions, telling Flynn, Every adult, every person in Melanie's life failed her from the moment she was born, until the day I met her. Did I do the right thing? Of course not. For me, I was rescuing a friend, stepping up to the plate when no one else would. And I can't tell you enough. It was the biggest mistake of my life. Eric Winterst's involvement in Danny Paquette's death proved once and for all there was no connection between Danny's death and that of his mother, Rena. At the time Rena died,
在撰写他的书《我们的小秘密》时，作者凯文·弗林在监狱里探访了埃里克·温特斯特。埃里克对自己的行为表现出极大的悔意，告诉弗林：“从梅兰妮出生到我见到她的那天，她生命中的每一个成年人，每一个人都辜负了她。我做对了吗？当然没有。对我来说，我是在拯救一个朋友，在没人愿意站出来的时候挺身而出。我无法告诉你更多。这是我一生中犯下的最大错误。”埃里克·温特斯特参与丹尼·帕奎特的死亡事件最终证明，丹尼的死与他母亲雷娜的死之间没有任何联系。在雷娜去世时，
the prime suspect, Edward Coolidge, was under such intense police observation that some believe there was no way he could have killed her. To this day, the truth about Rena Paquette's death remains a mystery. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
主要嫌疑人爱德华·柯立芝受到警方的严密监视，以至于有些人认为他根本不可能杀害她。直到今天，关于雷娜·帕奎特死亡的真相仍然是一个谜。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。